salamanders are cool robots are cool
robot salamanders are awesome I respect
this robot and ferrets like Clara bot
was built in collaboration with
biologists to study how the spinal cord
and the nervous system work together to
create motion it mimics a live
salamander using 27 motors controlling
11 different vertebrae this allows it to
move the spine in this s pattern that
means the diagonally opposite feet can
move in the same direction during a step
but how is this man-made robot mimicking
mother nature's design to make this a
realistic robot they took 3d x-ray video
of the salamander walking on the ground
walking underwater and swimming by
tracking 64 points on the skeletal
system they could create very accurate
three-dimensional models of the
salamander state could then use to mimic
the motion in pleura body like a real
salamander this robot has a low center
of mass making it extremely stable you
can also adjust its gait which allows
you to get over uneven ground
mother nature eat your heart out